louise est prévoyant l apprécier
préarrangements funéraires et bien
longtemps des années plus tard elle
reçoit un appel de la maison funéraire
qui lui demande
2600 $ de plus pour son nul louise est
surprise puisqu'elle à payer un forfait
tout compris
l'exposition le transport la cérémonie
la crémation et l'urne le service de
pompes funèbres peut-il réclamer ces
frais supplémentaires
non louise à payer le prix demandé au
début des années 90 et ce prix ne peut
être modifié avec le temps depuis 1988
au québec
la loi exige qu'à la maison funéraire
des pauvres 90% des sommes payées dans
un compte en fidéicommis et elle peut
réclamer des frais supplémentaires
uniquement s'il ya des ajouts au contrat
le fin mot de l'histoire
la mort est une dette que chacun ne peut
payer qu'une fois